eh bien nous avons ici thierry lhermitte
qui a interprété le film les ripoux que
vous connaissez qui triomphent toujours
d'ailleurs je crois qu'il est toujours à
l'affiché du film de claude zidi avec
philippe noiret et notre notre caméra
cachée de ce soir pourrait s'intituler
le rythme car jacques legras joue
vraiment un flic ripoux jusqu'à la
moelle puisqu'ils demandent de l'argent
pour pour de vote donnaient
renseignements dans la rue c'est pour
vous dire alors quelle va être la
réaction des passants est ce qu'ils vont
payer
il ya catherine alary qui amorce la
situation le renseignement vous demander
de lefranc de se rendre leur
enseignement s'il vous plaît et oui on a
des frais de son roulement des
enseignements mais moi j'ai mon parti à
payer ses courses et je mets une pièce
alors vous prenez oui vous prendre
montée prenez la deuxième
demandé de prendre les commandes
et puis comme ça non moi je fais depuis
pas mal de temps déjà
comment j'ai pas de four n'a pas de sens
et vous vouliez un renseignement
c'est la vraie fiction non il ya trois
mois seulement
mais paul lay le font pas c'est mes
collègues ne le font pas oui il y en a
je les collais qui donne des
renseignements gratuits vous savez il ya
les avants de la rochelle
oui elle va me donner à leur redonner le
franc je vous le dis nous c'est fort et
profond
oui
alors voilà cinq francs je vois la
jouant de francs alors franklin delano
roosevelt résille est que le
renseignement
écoute moi
moi oui soit payer les renseignements
personnellement c'est pour moi c'est
parce que j'ai les frais de parking les
frais d'essence des frais d'essence les
frais d'essence et tout ça vous
comprenez vous comprenez
mais pas deux
moi j'ai téléphoné à lisieux raison
c'est tout
je voulais pas me donner et l'italienne
est conforme le pack français du doigt
et les voyages de la compagnie voyez ce
genre de mourir
vous pouvez me donner de francs pour
elle voilà les sujets l'agencé quand
même
c'est tout à fait personnel voilà merci
c'est pour moi non le renseignement
c'est pour le renseignement pour savoir
où les champs elysées maintenant vous me
donnez de molière
je peux vous dire on faisait des
missions pour la télévision française
pour antenne 2 nous étions film est
actuellement vous a fait je remercie
oui voilà c'est ça les sentiments vous
me les deux fronts
deux sens entre le renseignement
merci parce qu'on a on a des faibles à
la vénérable
comme andré freiner le cuir
oui oui mais je vous demandais si vous
demandez un renseignement je vous
demande et 2 de la saison de
renseignements mais je me fiais parce
que j'ai des frais et léger chez des
frais est parti j'ai ma voiture là et
vous mettre des sous pour le parti vont
pousser alors comment sur soi vu qu'on
se connaît oui je vous demande et deux
français double commande
oui
ah non c'est moi personnellement je peux
payer moins personnellement si vous avez
de france vous ne levez le renseignement
enfin si c'est mon devoir
si vous les laissez vous me donnez de
francs avait pas de problème si moi je
moi je crois personnellement si je ne
donne rien renseignements personnels
soudain deux sens où les pas le savoir
bon voila vous me donnez pas de foin
touboul - oui prenez un renseignement
pour y reposent ces deux fronts
post 2 2 francs le renseignement avec
parce que c'est obligé vous comprenez
moi qui ont jalonné ma vie c'est pas ça
mais j'aime beaucoup de frais alors je
suis obligé de j'ai pris ma voiture et
pour le parking c'est cette pratique et
vous voulez alors d'euros de postes à
pour la poste la poste c'est de francs
de plus pour la bosnie
les pour les rues largement werner les
pattes romaine et pour la poste c'est
tout faire
les renseignements n'ont écouté j'ai
joué expliqué je vais vous donner le
renseignement deux chambres le
renseignement
je manque de sens parce que
j'ai pas mal de ce fait à ce moment
je remercie abbas est la première à
gauche tandis qu'il vous plaît et
l'avenue montaigne cola iberia oui je
vous demandais volet l'enseignement je
vous demande et deux français open à
dire font toujours de personnel version
j'aime seulement la voiture
quant aux narines faudrait moi vous
savez dès que j'arrive quelque part et
on connaît pas ça fait toujours plaisir
trouver quelqu'un qui peut l'aider
évidemment c'est ça finalement oui oui
l'avenue montée où ils s'étaient c'est
assez simple ou d'un mur en ciment
vous êtes un semblait alors je vous
demande et 200 pour le
parce que des tables du goût c'est ça ça
fait 2 c de francs par personne
une raison assurant seulement avoir oui
des laïcs et rien pour l'avenue mentez
joffrin je vous fais un prix à l'enjeu
est imprudent sont allemands l'ont
fonctionnement
chez trois jours en vo de francs non
joués a cédé pour la caméra cachée une
histoire maths et des missions